au Japon
La question de savoir si le produit est supérieur ou non
L'axe d'évaluation est au premier plan
Je pense que c'est l'essentiel, mais la France
L'outre-mer n'est pas ce genre d'axe d'évaluation
Au fait, je pense que vous m'évaluez.
Souvent des artistes, surtout en France
C'est dit, mais en fait l'artiste
C'est appelé à
quand dit
Je me demande si c'est vrai
Après réflexion
une personne qui fabrique des produits
Je suis conscient donc mon travail est
Nakute Start National Labon
Fondamentalement oui, juste mes pensées
Il y a une tendance selon laquelle faire est considéré comme une bonne chose
Je pense, mais je suis vraiment ego
Recherche, impressions des fans, etc.
après avoir entendu
Il y a des avis très durs, mais oui
Par quoi êtes-vous influencé ?
n'est pas affecté par
En fin de compte, c'est à toi
Je pense que c'est la capacité
Mais prends-le et réfléchis
Je l'ai fait parce que je pensais qu'il valait mieux être flexible
Ce qui m'a le plus influencé, ce sont les opinions des fans.
D'un autre côté, s'il s'agissait de changer l'histoire
C'est au tout début que j'ai arrêté de lire
Un fan commente votre blog
Je te l'ai donné
C'est très bien
Il y a eu un effet que mon hésitation a été époustouflée
Hé
[musique]
au Japon
Évaluation si le produit est supérieur ou non
l'axe est droit devant
Je pense que c'est l'essentiel, mais la France
L'outre-mer n'est pas ce genre d'axe d'évaluation
Au fait, je pense que vous m'évaluez.
Souvent des artistes, surtout en France
C'est dit, mais en fait l'artiste
C'est appelé à
quand dit
Je me demande si c'est vrai
Après réflexion
une personne qui fabrique des produits
Je suis conscient donc mon travail est
donc pas grand chose
Eh bien, ce qu'on appelle l'art proprement
Des occasions d'étudier des choses que vous ne comprenez pas bien
j'ai l'impression de ne pas l'avoir fait
artiste ou autre
C'est vrai, je suis un peu
C'est peut-être juste que je ne comprends pas
Je ne peux pas le faire, mais oui
Google
choisissons
C'est vrai, je n'étais pas digne de l'original
Cependant, j'ai dit qu'il y avait
anime
j'ai un petit conseil pour toi
il y a encore quelque chose comme ça
Lequel est le final
C'est subtil, mais juste comme une image
Pour le dessin animé
comme un groupe live
On dirait une chanson live, mais l'anime
Exactement ça
Enregistré
Une sorte d'orchestre de CD édités
C'est une image comme un arrangement
Game of Thrones je pense maintenant
Cette conversation est très attirante.
Je n'en avais pas beaucoup au Japon.
L'ironie du monde occidental, en particulier du Royaume-Uni
Je pense qu'il y a quelque chose que je veux continuer à dire
mais
C'est intéressant que la conversation soit presque ironique
C'est exact
touché par le sarcasme
cette conversation
La façon dont vous parlez affecte grandement la sensation de la conversation
reçu
Ma vie est toujours comme ça pour toujours
Il y a toujours un sentiment que je ne pense pas que ça va durer
Je vais
D'une certaine manière déjà
Oui, Attack on Titan s'est vendu et a fait de l'argent
j'en ai beaucoup
Eh bien, je ne sais pas quand je vais manquer de papier
Dans une situation mondiale aussi vague que
tel ou tel
Je pense que tout le monde a un sentiment de crise.
Est-ce à propos
C'est exact
dessins animés ou œuvres
la très
Même les gens de pays avec des cultures et des histoires différentes
On peut voir les mêmes choses et les apprécier de la même manière
que
Le sentiment d'être connecté
ça très
je pense que c'est bien
Anime japonais à l'étranger sur YouTube
Je regarde souvent les réactions
J'aime ça
un peu par pays
Il y a différentes manières de réagir
Mais en général, j'ai l'impression d'être connecté
je peux devenir
musique de visa
Je ne sais pas si c'est une histoire intéressante
Conseils
que
Blue Rock ou la famille Spy"
Saviez-vous que
Les deux œuvres ont beaucoup aidé Attack on Titan.
de ceux qui ont reçu
C'est un dessin animé
Non, c'est vrai
Qu'est-ce que M. Endo de la famille d'espionnage Endo?
que
Rivaux pour jouer au tennis de table
M. Endo devrait être extrêmement plus fort
Mais pour une raison quelconque, Endo-san n'est pas bon à mon service
dans
J'ai gagné